thank you
[Music]
so uh while we were away from JK crazy
[__] started happening in Russia oh yeah
you were texting us about it yeah dude
I'm not a group
it's Friday like two weeks ago basically
and all of a sudden it starts exploding
all over Twitter that Russia is going
through a coup like a military style
cuisine nuts it's all crazy which means
that Putin you know the idea is that
Putin was going to be replaced by this
group called The Wagoner group or the
Wagner is what everyone say but they are
like a a mercenary group of like 25 000
soldiers that's Putin hired to help
um beat Ukraine and then they were
turning on Putin and marching all the
way towards Moscow because they said
that the Russian military
um bombed their bases betrayed them
killed some of their soldiers and on top
of that they said that the Russian
military was very incompetent and then
they got their soldiers killed for
following their orders so that's why
they said time for Revenge [__] ass
they think and and there's also part of
that too is you know there's some who
believe that Russian military leadership
is being too [__] about Ukraine they
want them to just go in and [__]
level the place win the war damn yeah so
they took over like a southern base that
was like the control center for the
Ukraine war and then they took over that
and then they were marching on their way
to Moscow and then somehow it stopped
just completely and they were taking
over these regions with no fighting no
fighting but then there's a couple
helicopters that got down I think yeah a
couple helicopters cut down whose side
on Russia's side I've seen some of those
videos it looks [__] scary as [__] to
see something flying and then just drop
straight down to helicopters with no
fatalities no no they were fatalities on
the on the Russian side they were I'm
talking about the air the the in the air
there were fatalities yeah but there was
no resistance marching through yeah like
they were just driving and there's even
some Russian military that flipped on
the Wagner side too and then um and all
of a sudden on the way to Moscow like 15
miles away they stopped and then they
broke a deal with a Belarus whoa yeah so
the uh the president of Belarus
basically said hey we'll give you safe
harbor over here you guys can chill over
here and then Putin said hey I you know
the guy
um pragosian who's in charge of their
forces he's allowed to flee to Belarus
and Putin's says it's all good but what
does that mean I mean and then uh yeah
well the Belarus dude was like we'll
give you a base
that you can you know bring whoever
wants to follow so 25 000 mercenaries
are going to go to Belarus not everyone
but then the Putin also gave them like
um amnesty or just basically was like if
you want to
um join the Russian military like we'll
welcome you and then
um the base that he allowed Wagner to
move to is like super close to Keith
and that's the thing so which so people
are saying is this a move by Putin to
flush out people who weren't loyalists
perhaps test his own forces see who's
going to be a down ass [__] and who's
not oh [__] who flipped right that is
very you know where the convincing part
is of that because I just thought that
was like oh what a funny like Theory
right but then the backing behind it is
purgojin the the leader of the Wagner
group
um Putin made them they and they're like
decades old friends interesting same
with the Belarusian president and
they've been homies for years for many
many years so it's like why all of a
sudden now I was flagging it for some
other reason that was maybe the reason
right we don't know but the main reason
is a loyalty test of your own forces do
you think that's what is most likely in
your opinion dude I don't [__] know
honestly because I don't understand
Russian politics at all seems like a
really expensive loyalty test yeah
exactly and why would Putin want to make
himself look like [__] to the world
Community like now that doesn't that's
not a Putin move no now China is going
to see them as weaker because like hey
dude you just got almost waffle stomped
and then all of a sudden they just
decided to turn back at the to go to
Belarus yeah because when I first heard
of that I was like okay so that bricks
thing is not gonna happen anymore right
you know because it's like Russia makes
up a big part of it so if like the
[__] thread starts pulling out then
what other country oh [__] rushes out
their [__] together what it needs China
[__] Us in like India whatever it's
all make this work but if this guy's not
then I don't want to and then it just
goes back you know interesting so I'm
like there's gonna be huge repercussions
from this thing like do you think the
Iranians view Putin is stronger now like
I don't think so yeah that doesn't seem
like a that is crazy that a mercenary
group
which is like private can be almost as
strong as an actual country boy if but
the the idea is that maybe Russian
forces are so exhausted by the war yeah
that and a lot of moms in Russia right
who have dead um children maybe there's
a lot of sentiment in Russia that's
anti-war now yeah and so those guys were
able to walk into territories because I
saw videos of Russian citizens giving
the Wagner group guys like bottled water
and food wow
so so that's like our like if our black
water was able to like
like actually move on our military
that's pretty that's crazy how many
members are there for Blackwater I don't
know I think they they actually
dispersed like or they changed the name
of the company I don't think they're I
think they're called Pelican now or
something yeah but they just changed her
name Academy and they're called now oh I
got it but there's a bunch of them
they're not the only ones there's like a
bunch of um
a bunch of mercenary groups in in
America twenty to thirty thousand whoa
black water guns wow that's like Wagner
group then [__] crazy oh damn and so
most of these people are made up of like
ex military most are ex-military yeah
they just want to keep like what's the
motivation for someone from the U.S
military to want to be immersed so they
like what they do yeah like they like
being an operator like being in the
field they like having cool tactical
[__]
um but maybe they don't
um want to keep doing the missions of
the country and they'd rather be a
person for hire and they get paid way
more they get paid way more they get to
have a weapon of choice you pretty much
you get to do all the fun [__] that you
used to do but take away all the hard
[__] so now you have like because aren't
they just mainly protecting the assets
of like offshore like
businesses oil-based or whatever the
companies are contracted to be secure
that could be so like let's say like KFC
is going to build [__]
uh locations in Iraq as they move the
base forward and then like let's say the
the main KFC guy's gonna go over there
he'll be protected by two protected by
six mercenary black quarter guys
and the recipe they got the recipe in a
briefcase with a handcuff and a
briefcase are there ever any missions
where like military will have to team up
with black water or like private
military yeah sometimes side by side
yeah if they don't have enough resources
they'll team up they have to how's the
sentiment between them it's pretty cool
they're buds a lot of them are like from
what they say the way Merc yeah yeah
so they're like yeah they're Brothers
they're Brothers ah I'll let you just do
this like we were both seals now you
just do the private stuff I do this uh
because I was even reading how like
those guys
um
even from European and those countries
all join them too oh so it's like an
international like yeah because it's a
private company and they probably need
people and then they'll get other
languages French legionnaires and stuff
yeah yeah they have different
connections from other countries it
makes sense but apparently a lot of
their philosophies change about country
loyalty after they go to war and they go
oh everyone's doing the same thing like
everyone just has special ops in
different countries it's no good guy no
bad guy everyone's just it's a war game
dude that's that's the crazy thing of
that I found out about
um like when we were on tour we had a
security guy
um and he was uh he was marine and then
he did private and then whenever we went
to different countries he had a guy
always meet him at the airport and he
would give him a gun yeah that's cool
nuts that's crazy that's how the movies
bro yeah
I know he was like yeah this is very
normal though like you just kind of keep
just have your own contact yeah yeah or
a locker filled guns and he gives it a
key
passports wow
that's so cool inventory and they got a
computer guy who's just hacking in the
Mainframe yeah he said because he said
he's he's uh he's the American he lives
in Vegas actually but then he said he's
the American for another guy that'll
come like
he'll give him a gun like it's like a
[__] thing it's a cool thing one of
these things yeah that's dope right they
do it for each other all the time oh wow
what kind of gun is it does he say I
have no I don't know I wouldn't know a
[__] gun from a swords
[Laughter]
freaking Samsung remote for all I know
for some scale right the um what's kind
of wild about what just happened Russia
has like a million soldiers right one
point one five million is the estimated
amount world's fifth largest military
force these 25 000 dudes just marched
all the way up to Moscow and they were
scared of them exactly these guys are
probably all like former special ops so
they're like way more highly trained
like usually it's like the higher level
guys that do the mercenary stuff wow and
Putin eight hours prior to the deal
getting
it giving a statement saying these guys
are Traders we're gonna [__] you up
we're gonna [__] you up hard and then
eight hours later he's like it's all
chill yeah uh it's all good do you think
we'll ever know the real freaking
dialogue between that yeah not for 20
years or something because that might be
misinformation too about like oh he
planned it this way because he might
have been like oh [__] they can see how
vulnerable we were but then he can get
out that news be like no we planned it
and then he's like guys we gotta get our
act together you guys are really mad at
us it's crazy that one of the world's
superpowers almost had a coup that's
[__] crazy it was crazy too to see oh
all the hardcore right Wingers like um
the the
um the guys who were basically like at
all times like Putin needs to go
whatever like Lindsey Graham's and all
those guys like the guys were like no
matter what Putin has to go and we're
gonna get Putin by exhausting him by
doing this war and then they're like
basically popping champagne bottles
early on Twitter and [__] being like
it's Putin's last day let's get Putin's
final days in office and all this [__]
and then those guys all got wrecked like
within hours
it's like global politics like in the
the way that people started dunking on
other people shifted immediately the
other direction it was so anti-climactic
though I thought there was going to be
like at least a resistance fight or
something any article of it no it
literally says in the Wikipedia article
like uh you know Wikipedia always makes
you put dates and times when things
happened and stopped so instead of
saying like uh coup began coup ended it
just says reason for stopping everyone
went home so good that's so funny and
they literally did yeah wow and some of
the wider guys just went home some of
the Wagner guys went to Belarus I don't
know how any that gets parsed out yeah
me me that's scary you know it blows my
mind though like in the world that we
live in and the life we have here it's
hard enough to keep uh to stay in the
middle of all of your friends political
beliefs without losing them right yeah
imagine if you're a [__] politician
and you have to stay in the middle of
these guys oh man like it could mean
death
close your house you have to you have to
like play nice with everybody [__] that
dude I know or even like people that are
on opposite sides publicly but they're
actually besties in real life yeah but
then on-screen debates [__] hate them
they hate me and then other photos
surface like they've been friends for
two decades they're like what the [__] I
love seeing Obama with like George W
like playing golf I'm always like yeah
exactly dude and then everybody's on the
Epstein list anyway
they're all friends what if that's the
reason they're hiding it it's because
they're gonna see that everyone's homies
It's gotta be the reason because
everyone's on the list even celebrities
and people like dude
that's I think that's the real con is
like
they think the saddest thing to me is
like whether you're Republican or
Democrat you really believe that those
people are trying to help you
that's that's very sad I don't think
that at all what do you think
I think I think uh I think they're there
to help us
cynics we're jaded yeah you guys are
jaded you guys but you guys don't have
faith in the [__] political system
anymore right in the system oh no I I
believe I believe all politicians I
believe all government all structures I
think the only group that was really
trying to help is triple A oh honestly
yeah you call them they come in 30
minutes they fix your little tire if
they were a political party I trust them
because they're way more efficient than
the DMV yeah maybe why who I don't trust
Salvation Army so why not why not I just
think they're I think they're Liars too
I think they're allegedly yeah I don't
have any proof but this is just a gut I
agree because they're not even an army
yeah exactly this is how I do all my
political things just where's the bets
at when I go there exactly they're just
shaking myself trying to take my money I
see a bunch of old grandmas yeah
[Music]
thank you